you talk about AI then of course that's
one of the most dominant themes here at
the festival yes there are those who
think that it will amplify human
creativity and those who think it will
stop us what's your view my intuition is
amplify the concept of Doomsday new
technologies is something that humans
are very good at people like to push
against new things they go into fear
what's going to be bad even in the last
couple of years it's been obvious to me
that this is an enhancer of course
there's going to be things that come
along with it that aren't ideal but the
reality is is that I don't see this
killing the human creative Spirit we
still have the input I think that's
going to be a big factor gee put your
hands in the air drinks in your cup if
you don't give a [__]